[Music]
apology
yes
and i assume cancer mcgoff apology being
substituted by councillor newton is that
correct no no no i'm not so qualified i
don't want to know
oh right purely there in the gallery
okay
right item two minutes of the community
and resources committee of the 14th of
march
pages three to seven reading from the
bottom
checking for accuracy first of all
no comments for that welcome chancellor
john
um
can we have a proposal to expand
proposing
[Music]
[Music]
thank you we move on to item three
action list
and i believe that he's been provided
with a
new action list up to date
um
which shows everything has been complete
are we happy with everything being
complete and what's contained therein
silence is gone no sorry just to spoil
the quiet um with the first action with
burial sites and absence of land
available
is that action still to be is that still
ongoing looking at that because i would
have thought that that must be kept on
the agenda
so should that be marked on going
it's a it's a it's a constant action for
our estates team and obviously something
will be considered in the production of
a new global plan so it's a work stream
that we can build into business plans um
and we can agenda it to come back to
community women's offering each decision
all right but i think that ought to be
known thank you
right
item for public contributions i'm told
we have no one registered
uh item
five
forward plan page nine
[Music]
um
i don't know if there are any comments
to that one
nope
so i can move on
item
six declarations of interest you're all
adults and you know the rules now and
this is just a reminder
item seven
agreement of agenda between parts one
and two
uh
there is a suggestive part to
two suggested part two items being
numbers 13 and 14.
for the benefit of members of the public
that means that
the items will be taken by members of
the council
without public involvement because they
involve finances or
things that do affect the council
in addition
i'm amalgamating item eight urgent
matters brought forward by the chairman
i do have an urgent matter but i want to
take it in part too also
so it's three items that are prepared i
would propose from the chair to into
part two
secondly by councillor long
all in favor
that is unanimous thank you
now item nine
[Music]
decisions taken under urgency pretty
juice pages 10 to 22.
you've taken that one
so don't
uh
are there any questions
some of us have signed their life away
okay
um but we were waiting for the coaching
money but we decided to go ahead and
lose the 36 and wait for the county
money to come in afterwards so that's
basically
well i think it's down basically usable
is it
using it
okay that is does it need noting or
just remember yes okay we're happy to
note it
we move on to
item
10
medium term financial strategy
on you go david you wouldn't just got
here in time but you made it
[Music]
don't do that
okay um luckily enough we've got a
presentation to remind you what i'm
going to say
so what will the presentation cover i
can't hear you very well
that's unusual
um uh what the presentation cover i'll
read it's not all it's not
[Music]
hello
[Music]
okay can you hear me now yes excellent
so what my presentation cover i recap
what was reported back to members during
the
2022-23 budget setting cycle and a brief
refresh on the key assumptions
and also go for what new financial
issues of the nerves
i'll go through some modeling of
different scenarios and then i'll just
summarize and take any questions and
that's fine
so what was reported at full council
back in february 2022
well the top chart shows we're
projecting deficits which would bounce
back and recover and almost bring us
back into balance by 2026-27
and a projected balance of the
transition in government-funded reserve
as you can see there would start off
here with 1.7 million the bar chart
that's in yellow and decline and the
utilization of that reserve to balance
out which would flatten out in 2025 26
2026 27 so we were reporting a deficit
we were reporting that we were using a
substantial proportion of our transition
government funded reserve which is the
reserve we used advanced projects
but that it would platter that plateau
out by 2025 26 2026 27 let's plan please
tell so what were the key assumptions in
the immediate financial strategy back in
february
pay award would be two percent for each
year on the immediate financial
structure
leisure costs would reduce the circuit
of 450 000 pounds per annum by 25 26
council tax would rise up to the
referendum limit for each year the
medium financial strategy which is five
pound per van d
about 2.9 slowly declining
and the increase employer pension
contributions and we assume that we have
increased planning and borrowed income
for the remainder of the duration the
immediate term financial strategy
that's likely
so
what's the emerging financial issues
currently housing benefits in relation
to homelessness it counts as i'm using
this loosely it's a way of regaining the
councils in that
we're told to minimize the use of
temporary accommodation and how to
benefit subsidy is designed to
disincentivize councils from using
temporary accommodation
and in two ways that's correct you know
people don't want to just if councils
have no incentive to move people out up
and breakfast accommodation because
they've been fully reimbursed from
housing so today their performance may
slack in someone
but the trouble is at the moment but
increased numbers of people putting
themselves at risk of homelessness
we put them into temporary accommodation
and we incur a lot of powers invented
subsidy but the exit strategy of finding
a sustainable tenancy for the person
isn't always already available to the
council
so we cannot
every time we get increased numbers of
homelessness there's an increased cost
of the council because we pay our bed
and breakfast and only get a small
proportion of that to come down
[Music]
back next slide please stop
salaries
i mean as everybody's aware the face of
a period of unprecedented inflation
probably since the mid 1970s
cost of utilities construction price
inflation particularly start
i assumed that's a lot of section one
part one officers did
that the pay away two percent over the
life of the mediator financial strategy
increasingly on information i'm getting
back from various
public bodies representative trade body
so to speak of district council society
network the local government
association the society of uh local
government and employers everyone's
saying that the payroll is going to be
difficult to keep the payroll to
percentage particularly the inflation is
six seven eight percent
and as paid represents by far the
biggest single expenditure for the
council increased pay awards above the
previous meetings and financial
projections represent the biggest
financial risk to the council
and we can't ignore the other inflation
pressures we've got in terms of fuel
utilities construction prices etc and
that's why i thought it's done
um the median term financial strategy we
assumed a cost of supplying leisure
now we're making some assumptions the
the leisure usage in a post-pandemic
environment
we've got less than complete information
from our previous operator so we've got
it not blind but we certainly haven't
gone in with full information available
to us
inflation is at historic high levels and
[Music]
utilities are a big cost for leisure
providers when you've got a swimming
pool
for heating
and then particularly like in holes
where it's not on the gas network it's
actually on
kerosene fuel and that's exceptionally
expensive at the moment
and also there's going to be pressure on
people's discretionary spend because
people are seeing increased utility
bills one of the first things people
might be able to do to retail their
outdoors would be their gym membership
well that's very quick
[Music]
only over time will the level of
financial corporate pride become truly
known
so many of our residents will increase
increased bills and financial searches
invasion pressures i see growth in their
income levels members may understandably
want to ease averting by not raising
council tax however the impact of not
raising council tax will cost the
council 125 000 pounds per annum
the low this lost income because the
referendum case will never be made up by
the council by a wave contest just to
say we don't increase the council
attachment maybe it costs about 125 000
pound years
the cost of one refused crew three years
about
[Music]
he takes his 100
wages agency baffled fuel and the
contribution to actually replacing the
vehicle at that end of his life and
tires with maintenance etcetera
next line
[Music]
so
i've modeled some scenarios
the blue line this is where i challenge
myself isn't it the blue line is what
was reported in february
the
orange line the optimistic line
shows um a decline in the transition
golden funding reserve we're going to
dance
the green lilac light gray line
and the likelihood shows that we're
going significantly overdraw and the
yellow line the pessimistic
essentially we're going over a financial
cliff and to be honest even the likely
and the pessimistic or severe financial
challenges for the council that's right
please tell them
so
talking to council is facing china
the homelessness crisis
and our statutory obligations in our
response to it
and instead therefore it's vitally
important that the member working group
that brought about tangible deliverable
actions to bring the bullet budgets back
into the balance if you want to say no i
can take questions
yeah i just have to take any questions
[Music]
all councils are facing the same
problems
so what sort of uh
[Music]
solutions of other councils come up with
or what's the general feeling and
certainly the lga about how it will go
forward
the reality is that it seems like every
authority is going to
go into debt and what the hell can you
do about it well i think we've already
seen the first steps in that level while
we've heard about saying carmel we're
going to be shutting larger facilities
yeah so
i think we're at the start of um a
unique period in local government
financing if i'm honest
and i think those things where you live
i'm saying legit facilities closing or
overclocking services or raising top
fees and charges
um
every council will have a unique sector
circumstances
and i think
the thing that worries me is that
we've already had our settlement for
2022-23 we haven't read the payroll for
2022-23
i think it's been something for the
impact of different levels of pay awards
there's such a significant it's up it
feels difficult for us to
hold the line at less than three and a
half percent
[Music]
a lot of uh well the politics will go
into it that they uh they won't be able
to many authorities won't be doing that
just borrowing today and borrow is is
the short-term solution
and really is supposed to borrow for
capital services primarily
so you shouldn't really be borrowing
just to bridge a gap in your ongoing
revenue budgets
are you to get to do that as a kind of
capitalization directions too yeah so
i'm saying we should borrow the capital
investment so the new environmental
center is legitimate reason why this
council will go up and borrow money
to borrow two million just about the
books is not
within our remit
just just drive a little bit to that
then so with with borrowing as david
said it's generally for a capital
investment um the government must do its
edu allowed um through capital
directions to
for councils to borrow but that's on the
back of doing kind of uh programs of
transformation that will deliver revenue
savings uh longer term but those
councils are the councils which are kind
of on the verge of
bankruptcy
[Music]
districts forum meeting which is um all
the the devil districts
on friday
as you said other councils are in the
same boat
but recognizing we've set up a budget
working group with members
with a view then to report back
in june july what the other authorities
in general are kind of planning to do
proposing to do and their circumstances
at least we get a demonstrated picture
of what's going on
counselor harley and
i noticed david alluding to uh feeding
charges i heard this morning on the news
87
have doubled charges in several of their
popular car parks
and obviously from the start of tourist
season and other car parks have gone up
by 50 percent they said they looked into
it
and this is the way
i mean
we recognize the fact that councils now
have to find other ways
of
increasing their finances the government
are destroying further in front of the
background at the time thank you
councillor
yeah i've picked up on devon lyons i
don't know if it is only a day old or
older than that that the government have
now announced their national pot of
funding and that it's going to be 1.4
billion in
2024
but for and it's going to be 400 million
in 2223
and torrents have been awarded one
million pounds we're seven one million
and all then one point two
four million so is that one million
pounds
incorporated in this
uh chair uh
no that's uh our share the uk shared
prosperity fund which is
meant to replace all the european
funding uh that was in place uh
pre-brexit
um
so the the million pounds charge is over
the next three years this year next year
and the year after um and that's
for specific types of
kind of regeneration
part of the leveling of white paper uh
for which we've got to produce an
investment plan which needs to be
submitted i think in the first of all by
the 31st of august this year so
that's around business support and that
type they can't just be used to to
balance the council's budget so that's a
completely different sector
yeah but we have got that one million
christine if that's one million over
three years how does that compare with
what we were getting before from the eu
has gone down or going forward
and um
without guess without
drawing into any political debate it has
gone down
significantly as you will have seen
cornwall's figures corner were promised
uh to have theirs replicated so they've
got 120
million i think so
um it's significantly reduced from what
was given through the eu programs
previously
not to give you specific figures or
whatever but to give you some context uh
the allocation isn't as big as even the
leader program that we ran through the
last round of building funds so that's
just one component of the european fund
so we've lost money through brexit
please
move it
that
you want to come in yeah
chairs just a couple of points or one
particular point trying to pick up so if
uh members recall back at full council
um you charged us and the leader and
deputy leader to contact our mps
geoffrey cox to make representation to
government about our settlement for this
financial year and you'll recall david's
through his presentation
did some uh charts showing our
comparison with other district councils
other types of councils across the
country other councils with similar
deprivation indices and you'll recall we
fell far below
the comparative increase
um so meeting was secured with kenny uh
badnock
who's a minister of state mp for
um
through their in dlex or part of michael
gold's team so
uh because of numbers in the in de la
crosse de la offices uh only david
myself and sir jeffrey were able to
attend so we had a meeting with kenny
with some of her officials to to point
out um some of the issues members raised
in light of our settlements last year
um so there were kind of three specific
areas
um the fact comparatively we were below
everybody else from below other
authorities in deprivation
um the impact of
changes to housing so you know we're all
aware of houses moving from the council
tax register the business rate register
and the increase in holiday length
second homes etc
and the third
point was are
part of our
settlement which incorporates the
rural elements we get additional funding
for
the costs of being a rural area wasn't
inflated
as were other parts of the grand
settlement and that is a significant
part of our settlement so they the three
points the three specific points
we took the the opportunity to talk a
little bit wider around the the housing
issues we are facing because obviously
that again is past part of the equation
as david pointed out
the homelessness issues as well as well
as some of the kind of economic problems
facing um torridge could be in a rural
area and a coastal area so we took the
opportunity to raise uh quite a bit uh
with the mp
um if the officials at the meeting tasks
then to go away and look in detail at
storage's circumstances and how we
compared to others and to try and
uncover the specific rationale for us
receiving a lower settlement and then
we'll be written to um
from from the office uh to torres and to
jeffrey uh with that information so
we'll wait uh to hear from that
okay any questions
well this item was promoting
in fairness i think we've noted it
uh so we'll move on now to item 11
exclusion of the public that we have a
formal vote where we say
thank you to members of the public for
attending but we've now got to go in the
private staff
can we have a vote to exclude the public
please
prepare i'll propose it central hudson
seconded those in favor
it is
unanimous
thank you